[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo
émission largement consacrée aux
élections législatives puisque la
campagne va prendre fin ce soir bonjour
michael bonjour katia bonjour a tous
notre invité cette semaine et bruno
cautrès bonjour bonjour vous êtes
chercheur au cevipof vous connaissent
évidemment tout ce monde politique
aujourd'hui un monde en bouleversements
vont en parler pendant toute cette
émission va revoir tout les temps forts
de cette semaine avec d'abord un état
des lieux de ce avant le deuxième tour
de l'élection de législatives aux
nouvellement recomposition verra aussi
les partis traditionnels leur avenir
à droite comme à gauche et puis on
parlera de la loi moralisation public
alors que françois bayrou est rattrapé
notamment par les affaires qui touchent
son parti le modem mais tout de suite le
cap sur le second tour des élections
législatives avec un raz-de-marée en
marche à l'horizon mais aussi du
renouvellement
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et c'est une assemblée effectivement
largement renouvelée qui se profile à
l'horizon avec beaucoup de novices et
aussi plus de femmes est à délier tout
de suite
mille cent quarante six candidats sont
en lice dimanche pour le second tour des
élections législatives
beaucoup de femmes se présentent presque
40%
le phénomène est inédit sous la vème
république la parité presque tenu parmi
elles 197 candidate investie par la
république en marche
l'assemblée sera aussi rajeuni avec une
moyenne estimée à 47 ans 24 candidats de
moins de 30 ans pourraient faire leur
entrée au palais bourbon l'hémicycle
accueillera aussi beaucoup de novices
dont la moitié n'a jamais exercé de
mandat électif
une majorité de ces nouveaux venus et
diplômés et appartient à des classes
aisées 577 députés seront élus dimanche
quatre ont déjà gagné leur siège à
l'issue du premier tour les autres
s'affronteront en duel
une seule triangulaire est prévue elle
aura lieu dans l'aube
alors bruno cautrès 1 ce dernier sondage
opinionway ne donne à la république en
marge de 440 à 470 sièges
une majorité plus écrasante est-ce que
vous parvenez à imaginer ce que ça peut
donner un chiffre aussi important c'est
vrai que c'est un chiffre impressionnant
on a déjà eu des majorités qui était de
grosse majorité sous la vème république
1993 1980 en pas en particulier mais là
c'est vrai que c'est spectaculaire parce
que c'est la première fois qu'une seule
formation politique va voir autant de
députés et on va avoir à la fois un
phénomène spectaculaire et en même temps
un phénomène qui pose quand même un
certain nombre de questions puisque de
questions et de problèmes sans doute
problème à terme dans un premier temps
des questions qui sont est ce bien
normal dans une démocratie où toutes les
tendances politiques devraient être
représentés dans la chambre qui fait la
loi est ce que c'est normal qu'une seule
formation politique puisse avoir autant
de sièges donc ça va à nouveau poser des
questions sur le scrutin majoritaire
mais alors c'est aussi un effet de
l'abstention c'est aussi un effet du
fait que les autres électorat ne se sont
pas déplacés tu as forcément
représentative alors de l'état réel
voilà c'est intégré quand on parle de
la représentativité parce que ils vont
être bien sûr légitime et représentatifs
des électeurs qui les ont évidemment
mais par contre l'amplification qui est
donnée par le scrutin majoritaire et par
l'abstention donne à cette ce parlement
cette assemblée nationale qui va arriver
dimanche prochain eh bien il ya quand
même un contraste entre le premier tour
de la présidentielle est le résultat des
législatives le premier tour de la
présidentielle a montré une france
beaucoup plus diversifiée
sociologiquement politiquement alors
qu'à l'issue du deuxième tour des
législatives on va avoir une assemblée
nationale très homogène politiquement et
relativement homogènes sociologiquement
gîte imiter des urnes pas forcément
légitimité aux yeux de la populaire n a
pas forcément légitimité politique à un
moment donné où le gouvernement veut
légiférer sur des thèmes qui sont des
thèmes qui sont fortement sujet à débat
la réforme des retraites la réforme de
l'indemnisation du chômage le contrat de
travail donc des choses qui touchent les
français et en plus qui font débat et
qui ont déjà fait débat donc on va voir
à un moment donné le gouvernement qui
peut être éventuellement un peu en porte
à faux entre l'envi de légiférer et s'en
sont nazes il y avait une majorité aussi
absolue c'est un inconvénient
oui ça peut être un avantage je pense
que globalement c'est plutôt un
inconvénient qu'un avantage c'est un
avantage pour le gouvernement
républicain devant c'est là qu'on voit
la très confortable bien sûr et qui ne
va pas rencontrer d'opposition à court
terme d'accor à moyen terme et à plus
long terme vers la fin du mandat
ça devient un inconvénient parce que
bien sûr au fur et à mesure qu emmanuel
macron va vouloir développer ses projets
va devoir présenter des projets de loi
avec edouard philippe progressivement va
apparaître la critique qui est mais tout
ça n'est pas représentatif après tout il
n'avait fait que 24% au premier tour de
la présidentielle dans la réalité
voilà voilà donc je pense qu'à terme ça
va quand même posé des soucis il
reviendra au nouveau premier ministre et
au président et à la majorité de trouver
les moyens d'instaurer du dialogue entre
la diversité des points de vue
et leur proposition de loi est d'autant
plus vrai qu'en plus ce thème de
légiférer différemment de de redonner de
la vie au débat démocratique au
parlement
ce sont des thèmes sur lesquels emmanuel
macron est constamment venu il ya deux
députés qui ont été élus en marche
évidemment qui ont été élus dès le
premier tour
ils ont fait leur apparition cette
semaine à l'assemblée nationale pour
reprendre leur petite mallette
évidemment l'intérieur on y trouve vous
savez quitte le clift nécessaire à tout
député c'est sylvain maillard on va sur
l'image est ce que vous trouvez vous que
on a on dit beaucoup qu'on va avoir
affaire à des novices est ce que vous y
croyez vous à ce mundo vis ou au
contraire est-ce qu'ils vont être très
encadrée alors ce qui est sûr c'est que
cette assemblée nationale qui s'annonce
dimanche
elle va avoir des députés effectivement
novice au sens qui n'ont jamais été élu
jusqu'à présent alors quand on regarde
les études que nous avons conduite au
cevipof on voit que les novices certains
d'entre eux ont déjà été candidat à des
élections locales même s'ils n'ont pas
été élus d'autres ont eu des
responsabilités
d'accord on voit la fédé l'opposition
finalement vous voilà alors ce sont des
ce sont des novices certains d'entre eux
vont être vraiment vraiment vraiment des
novices mais la plupart de ces novices
ont déjà exercé des responsabilités dans
la vie économique ou ont déjà exercé des
responsabilités dans la vie citoyenne
ce n'est pas la vie politique n'est ce
pas la ville vrai différend politique
quand vous êtes un chef d'entreprise et
ses rythmes et bien sûr ça c'est un des
éléments qui va être très intéressant
c'est de voir comment ces nouveaux
députés novice dans la sphère le
politique vont pouvoir ou pas
s'acclimater et venir les clubs culture
certains viennent du business de
l'entreprise du monde économique
comment ils vont adapter leur culture
professionnelle à la vie parlementaire
oui mais alors justement est-ce que ça
le celui qui vient du monde de
l'entreprise il peut apporter quelque
chose à la nouvelle assemblée
même si le rythme ne sera pas le même
celui de l'entreprise n'est pas celui
des difficultés qu est d'admettre que la
vie publique la décision publique n'a
pas exactement le même rythme que la
décision vraiment de l'entreprise il y a
également une image peut-être qui a
frappé
cette semaine les français et peut-être
ce deuxième tour l'entre-deux tour de
cette élection législative c'est cette
image de l'agression dont a été victime
nathalie kosciusko morizet sur un marché
ça s'est passé jeudi
qu'est ce que vous a inspiré cette
violence bien bien sûr c'est consternant
de voir que dans un pays grand pays
démocratique que nous sommes on puisse
voir ce type de ce type de comportement
bien sûr ça rappelle que l'engagement
public l'engagement dans la vie dans la
vie politique ne vous fait pas que des
amis et il ya par ailleurs des je pense
qu'il ya une tonalité un petit peu
générale dans le pays que nous avions
observé très bien avant la séquence
électorale dans notre baromètre de la
confiance politique que nous publions
une fois par an au cevipof et qui
montrait qu'une partie l'électorat était
au delà de la critique vis-à-vis des
hommes politiques
peut-être au-delà de la défiance dans le
manque de respect dans l' enquête on
avait observé que pratique dans la
moitié des français disaient que les
hommes politiques ne mérite aucun
respect c'est un cap en avant votre
élection avec un cap
plein cap était été été franchi
l'évolution de la vie politique et de la
vie publique depuis ces dernières années
a été une évolution allant dans le bon
sens qui est de montrer que les hommes
politiques sont davantage proche des
français de désacraliser au bon sens du
terme
les responsabilités politiques il ya une
bonne bonne très bons aspects de sa qui
est de rapprocher mais là on est
vraiment dans autre chose et on est
effectivement dans ce côté un peu sombre
de la défiance politique qui est le
manque de respect le sentiment que au
fond on ne mérite aucune considération
il faut bien sûr souhaité que la
personne qui est responsable de ces de
ces agissements soient rapidement
interpellés et sanctionnés alors dans ce
paysage renouvelait qui se profile à
l'horizon
on se pose une question que vont devenir
les partis traditionnels
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
les résultats de ce premier tour des
élections législatives sont un coup
d'assommoir à droite comme à gauche à
droite on tente de retrouver une
boussole
voyons ce qu'a été la semaine chez les
élèves avec ce sujet de stéphanie des
pierres après le séisme du premier tour
françois baroin reprend son bâton de
pèlerin dans le xviie arrondissement de
paris
il vient soutenir brigitte kuster la
candidate et l'air en ballottage
défavorable pour tenter de remobiliser
ses électeurs la droite dramatise et met
en garde contre une hégémonie macro à
l'assemblée ça n'est pas bon ce n'est
probablement d'ailleurs pas bon pour le
président de la république j'ai moi-même
appartenu à une majorité obèses en 93
j'étais d'ailleurs le benjamin de
l'assemblée nationale quatre ans plus
tard nous avons été en difficulté nous
avons perdu le pouvoir donc je pense
qu'un équilibre à l'intérieur d'une
assemblée où chaque composante
républicaine pourra valablement faire
entendre sa voix ici à paris avec
brigitte kuster un peu partout en france
que je vais continuer à faire en une
semaine ce sera utile pour le débat
démocratique pour l'action au service de
la france ont pour la première fois il
ne pourrait y avoir aucun député de
droite à paris au total les républicains
espèrent sauver à peine une centaine de
députés alors faudra-t-il ou non
travailler avec emmanuel macron hier au
bureau politique
jean-pierre raffarin a voulu ouvrir le
débat fin de non recevoir l'ancien
premier ministre a failli claquer la
porte
le bureau politique a donc remis à la
semaine prochaine tous les débats sur la
ligne politique
les républicains essaye de faire bloc
jusqu'au second tour mais tous sont
d'accord
après il faudra tout changer le
fonctionnement des républicains est un
cauchemar
c'est à dire que depuis à oui on paye sa
très chère très chère
on paye sa très chère et ma foi j'ai
l'impression qu'on aura beaucoup de mal
à s'en relever faut tout remettre à plat
et plus vite savoir est-ce qu'on peut
rester tous ensemble
l'explosion j'en sais rien en tout cas
les faux semblants
ça suffit il nous faudra un leader il
nous faudra rebâtir construire et encore
une fois nous payons très cher la
primaire parce qu'on ne gagne pas avec
un programme pour une primaire on gagne
avec un programme pour la france
le début de l'avenir des républicains
commence donc la semaine prochaine le
bureau politique prévue au lendemain du
second tour s'annonce rude et ce bureau
politique aura finalement lieu mercredi
21 juin 17h bonjour stéphanie des
pierres bonjour vous avez suivi et vous
suivez cette actualité très mouvementée
au sein dlr petite question simple que
vont devenir les élèves ont-ils un
avenir et vers où et bien pour l'instant
tout le monde est un peu dans le
brouillard tout le monde au parti et les
républicains attend dimanche soir pour
pouvoir se compter notamment ceux qu'on
appelle les constructif c'est à dire
beaucoup d'anciens juppéiste beaucoup de
le mée restée notamment l'ancien premier
ministre jean pierre raffarin
tout dépendra de dimanche soir si ses
députés là sont très nombreux alors il
ya deux solutions
au départ il envisageait de faire un
deuxième groupe à l'assemblée une
scission du groupe l'est républicain
l'assemblée là ils sont en train de se
dire que peut-être il pourrait être très
nombreux et peut-être avoir la majorité
après l'élection dimanche auquel cas
thierry solère par exemple a en tête
d'essayer de prendre la présidence du
groupe l'est républicain à l'assemblée
assure qu'il y arrive il faudra vraiment
compter ils vont se compter dimanche ce
sera leur première leur première mission
dont il veut interroger renault 4 l
instant mais mercredi déjà d'une part on
va lire aussi peut-être le président du
groupe à l'assemblée nationale c'est le
jour où tout explose ça peut arriver ça
dans le parti des républicains
alors oui ça peut arriver tout peut
exploser mercredi le bureau de politique
a été reportée de lundi à mercredi on en
disait que ça leur exprès pour pouvoir
être après l'élection du président de
groupe l'est républicain l'assemblée et
c'est ça qui donnera le la est ce qu'il
y a un groupe est ce qu'il y en a deux
est-ce que c'est thierry solère ou
est-ce que c'est christian jacob qui
prennent la tête du groupe et à ce
moment là tout est possible
il ya clairement des élus qu'ils se
disent on peut plus rester tous ensemble
de groupe à l'assemblée je suis pas aux
lignes je suis pas dire s'il ya bien sûr
de ligne mais deux groupes d'abord il
faut avoir les moyens de sa politique
scélérate deux groupes ça veut dire
quand même beaucoup de conséquences
extrêmement pratique de groupe savent
aussi à terme ça veut dire deux
organisations à ces différentes donc dé
doubler les moyens pour un parti qui
voit son nombre d'élus considérablement
réduit et ses financements publics aussi
considérablement réduit tout ça n'est
pas totalement simple et par ailleurs on
sait que la logique d'avoir des groupes
c qui inévitablement ces deux groupes
sont amenés à un moment donné à se
confronter peut pas avoir ne voteront
pas de la même façon ils disent nous ne
faisons que collaborer en parce que si
on se comprend pas pourquoi il ya 2 il
ya deux groupes
donc s'il ya deux ans après avoir tourné
dans le reportage il ya deux lignes sont
très bas mais aujourd'hui même fracturé
lors de l'est républicain bon on le
savait avant la présidentielle
l'asec lattes de grand voile a sacré
atout grand jour dans un premier temps
l'explication a été que c'était la faute
de françois fillon maintenant c'est la
faute à la primaire mais on voit bien
qu'il ya au fond à guignen faute alors
voilà il ya des cultures différentes au
sein de la droite
elles ont du mal à coexister entre elles
et en toile de fond il ya bien sûr les
débats qu'on connaît bien à droite
depuis une dizaine d'années alors ses
fans il ya quelque chose d'important qui
va arriver dès que la nouvelle assemblée
telus y aura le discours de confiance du
premier ministre edouard philippe
puisque pour les républicains
ce discours voter ou pas la confiance au
premier ce sera la future ligne de
fracture
oui ça va fracturé ça va cristalliser en
tout cas les oppositions au sein du
parti des républicains
certains disent déjà qu'ils vont voter
la confiance dont tous les maquereaux
compatibles ce sont souvent des proches
même au point de vue personnel d'edouard
philippe une certain bruno le maire dont
ils se disent on votera la confiance au
gouvernement et de refiler et toute une
autre partie des républicains dit hors
de question si on veut jouer notre rôle
d'opposant comme ça a été le cas on peut
être voter certaines lois mais pas tous
et il va falloir montrer que
l'opposition c'est un peu les
républicains m6 ont réduit un peu à peau
de chagrin puisque le groupe des
républicains devrait être divisé au
moins par deux dimanche soir merci
stéphanie pour votre éclairage vocaux 13
sans parler des républicains vont
maintenant parler de l'autre perdant de
cette élection c'est le parti socialiste
les socialistes qui espèrent garder
quand même une trentaine de députés mais
la plupart des sortants sont en grande
difficulté comme l'expliqué des amendes
à gaza
à côté de la longue liste des candidats
socialistes éliminé dès le premier tour
ils font figure de rescapé plusieurs
anciens membres du gouvernement restent
qualifiés pour le second tour
l'ancien ministre de l'agriculture
stéphane le foll arrive en tête dans la
sarthe
pareil pour l'ancien ministre de la
santé marisol touraine en indre et loire
mejia mail comme réelle doit se
contenter de la seconde place dans le
xviiie arrondissement de paris
devancé de dix points par le candidat
les républicains pierre yves bournazel
point commun de ces trois anciens
ministres il n'avait pas de candidat la
république en marche face à eux ce qui
n'est pas le cas de najat vallaud
belkacem en grande difficulté dans la
sixième circonscription du rhône
elle fait un score deux fois inférieur à
son adversaire dans marche bruno bonnell
l'ancien premier ministre manuel valls
se présentait sans étiquette mais sans
adversaire du ps ou de la république en
marche
il affrontera une candidate de la france
un soumise au second tour parmi les
députés sortants qui espère encore être
reconduit le frondeur christian paul
level syst olivier dussopt pts ou encore
l'ancien président du groupe socialiste
à l'assemblée nationale
olivier faur monocoque presque le parti
socialiste peut qu'il faut qu'on joue un
rôle d'harry politique bien sûr mais pas
le même parti socialiste que celui que
nous avons connu on assiste aujourd'hui
d'une certaine manière à la fin d'une
aventure et qu'il aventure que françois
mitterrand avait engagé au parti
socialiste c'est à dire d'en faire à la
fois un parti incontournable de
gouvernement et un parti le parti le
plus important de la gauche tout ce que
vous dites c'est un changement de
logiciel
oui je pense que l'une des particules de
reconquête de la vente huet de cette
année si on l'a comparé par exemple à la
la grande défaite de 1993 pour les
socialistes mais en 1993 ils perdent
beaucoup de sièges
par contre ils ont leur logiciel c'est à
dire qu'après 93 on va voir
progressivement l'histoire de la gauche
plurielle en 95 lionel jospin et 1er du
premier tour de la présidentielle il
devient premier ministre en de
cohabitation 97 donc le ps de 93 est à
terre mais il a des
moyens pour se relever et pour
recommencer tout de suite eu hélas quels
sont ses moyens alors que là pour le
moment il est à terre mais sans boussole
et oui grignoter si vous voulez pas je
pense que la marge des deux côtés tout
compliquée et plus difficile pour le
parti socialiste non seulement compte
tenu de l'ampleur de la de la défaite et
des pertes en nombre de députés mais
aussi compte du fait que le parti
socialiste était au pouvoir
ces dernières années à la déroute
politique s'ajoute la déroute financière
puisque le parti va perdre large partie
de la subvention publique oui avec un et
l'avait d'ailleurs de spirale négative
les finances du parti c'est que non
seulement il va perdre une grande partie
de ces subventions publiques plus de la
moitié de ces subventions publiques de
l'ordre des deux tiers de ces
subventions publiques mais aussi ça va
sans doute avoir un effet cumulatif
puisque un parti qui est un peu en
déroute qui est en recherche de son
identité a moins de chances d'attirer
des militants dont cotisation de
militants en moins mais il a moins
d'élus dont contributions des élus en
moins mais sans doute aussi moins de
donateurs donc on voit qu'il ya pour le
parti socialiste
un enjeu qui est un enjeu fondamental
qui à la fois politiques et
d'organisations
c'est un enjeu de faire émerger un
nouveau leadership et progressivement de
faire émerger des thématiques sur
lesquelles contrer la république en
marche et la dynamique des manuels
macron pendant son mandat
alors y en a qui espère faire émerger
davantage son son parti enfin sable son
mouvement c'est jean luc mélenchon qui
espère avant le 15 députés nécessaires
pour former un groupe à l'assemblée fort
de ces de son résultat et de ceux des
autres candidats écouter l'appel qu'il a
lancé et qui s'adresse aux députés
socialistes frondeurs c'était en début
de semaine sur rtl écouter le
remplacement est en cours le
remplacement parce que le parti
socialiste est une structure qui a été
disqualifié par les électeurs pas par
moi moi je sais ce que j'en pense et je
sais pourquoi je l'ait quitté en 2008
mais il suffit pas qu'il soit
disqualifié pour le remplacer il faut
qu'il y ait une force alternative qui
soit l'acte soit capable de cristalliser
je me pose la question de savoir comment
les idées peuvent vivre ce qui compte
dans l'idéal socialiste cette sa
continuité
et comment il peut traverser le temps et
se renouveler en cours de route
c'est cet homme-là que je veux être
voilà aussi que les socialistes
n'avaient pas de boussole pour l'instant
est ce que lui il en a jean luc
mélenchon stratégie très claire qui est
d'occuper tout l'espace laissé à gauche
par la dynamique des manuels macron qui
lui a mangé le centre gauche et donc
jean luc mélenchon c'est tout l'espace
qui va de la frange delà du centre
gauche jusqu'à ce que jusqu'au que
ministre peut-être même au-delà
donc il veut devenir lui le nouveau
leader de la gauche pendant le mandat d'
emmanuel macron et il a une incroyable
puis arrivée ou pas il peut y arriver
parce qu'il a une incroyable scénario
pour lui qui est que d'une part s'il est
élu dimanche à marseille
alors qu'en même temps benoît hamon a
été sorti dès le premier tour pour lui
c'est évidemment une extraordinaire
opportunité parce qu'il peut montrer que
c'est lui le vrai leader et par ailleurs
la défaite de nombreux leaders
socialistes va priver le parti
socialiste à la fois bas de porte voix à
l'assemblée nationale mais aussi va
mettre en porte-à-faux ses leaders
socialistes a été battu aux législatives
pour se présenter comme des
personnalités qui incarnent le renouveau
donc jean luc mélenchon pour le moment
c'est plutôt pas mal pour lui c'est un
bon scénario même si bien sûr la france
est soumise ne retrouve pas les scores
de la présidentielle mais si on compare
aux partis de gauche au front de gauche
de 2012 car il améliore blessure en
pourcentage par rapport au front de
gauche de 2012
il ya eu un autre appel qui a été lancé
cette semaine aux électeurs pour
abstentionnistes notamment pour qu'ils
aillent voter c'est celui de marine le
pen elle était allée vous savez les
candidates à hénin beaumont et l'été
notamment à 67 fois lorsqu'elle a lancé
cet appel vous propose de l'écouter que
vient leur dire aujourd'hui un ceux qui
se sont abstenus au 1er tour vous devez
venir voter au second tour de ces
élections législatives c'est fondamental
si vous voulez défendre vos idées si
vous voulez défendre vos valeurs si vous
voulez vous opposer à la politique
emmanuel macron va mettre en oeuvre qui
va être une politique dévastatrice
vous parliez tout à l'heure de peut-être
probable succès pour jean-luc mélenchon
en tout cas d'une bonne réussite pour
marine le pen qui est arrivé 2 2
de l'élection présidentielle et ne
pourrait pas avoir de groupe et donc est
ce que pour marine le pen ça pourrait
être quand même une bonne solution
d'être député porte voix la semaine
nationale qu'une bonne solution pour
elle c'est vital sinon c'est quoi si
elle n'est pas élue députée de hénin
beaumont dimanche
elle va bien sûr avoir un porte à faux
dans son leadership
elle a été au cours des dernières la
dernière période la dernière ligne
droite de la présidentielle elle a été
un peu en porte à faux à l'assemblée ne
pas trouver son tempo dans la toute
dernière ligne droite le débat de
l'entre-deux-tours rater derrière à
l'assemblée à peu sans voix derrière sa
défaite à la présidentielle donc pour
marine le pen ya un an je fondamentale
compte tenu des critiques qui commencent
à apparaître au sein du front national
et peut-être même de divergences
stratégiques sur la stratégie vis-à-vis
des thèmes de forains philippot
notamment pour marine le pen ya un enjeu
ce d'heureuses se relégitimer donc y ait
des gens et du député oui il ya une
crise et lino si on lui met en doute
dans tout l'est maintenant toutes les
organisations politiques
la victoire d'emmanuel macron à père a
fait bouger a fait bouger les lignes a
fait apparaître aussi sans doute des
ambitions nouvelles à la terre de toutes
les organisations puisque le l'inde est
l'un des vraiment l'inde et l'une des
conclusions que beaucoup de jeunes
leaders à mon avis tirs dans les
différentes familles politiques
c'est dire mais après tout si emmanuel
macron y arriver pourquoi moi je vais
essayer de ne pas secouer mon
organisation et mon parti politique
yann ligne qui est en train d'émerger
aussi au sein du front national qui
était notamment proposé par marion
maréchal-le pen c'était celle de décès
tendre la main à la droite et d'incarner
cette droite pour demain est-ce que vous
pensez que c'est la ligne que doit
suivre le front national le front
national il a un problème pour
développer 7,7 cette ligne sans aucun
doute qu'une partie du front national
c'est que l'enjeu stratégique c'est
d'aller récupérer des électeurs qui sont
des électeurs de droite sensible aux
thématiques identitaires et un souci un
souci qui est un souci à la fois
sociologique et de deux lignes
politiques le souci sociologique c'est
que l'électorat du front national s'est
beaucoup un électorat de classes
populaires
travailleurs pauvres chômeurs jeunes
précaires personnes qu'on sentiment de
d'être d'être exclu de la compétition
économique et les thématiques
économiques de la droite sont plutôt des
thématiques qui est moins d'impôts moins
de fonctionnaires moins d'intervention
de l'état
donc à un moment donné au delà de toutes
considérations stratégiques pour réussir
cette opération d' attirer des électeurs
de la droite il ya une difficulté
programmatique
alors on va aborder le dernier grand
thème de la semaine le projet de loi
pour retrouver la confiance dans la vie
publique il a été présenté sur fond de
polémique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le texte a été présenté ce mercredi en
conseil des ministres objectif redonner
confiance dans notre vie démocratique
wass objectif problème le vis de la
justice défend son dossier alors qu'il
lui même dans la tourmente avec la faire
les assistants du modem
regardez ce sujet de rim benameur
un ministre embarrassant françois bayrou
a provoqué cette semaine le premier vrai
quoi gouvernementale
le garde des sceaux est en difficulté il
est fragilisé par des soupçons d'emplois
fictifs chez des assistants
parlementaires du modem
suite à ces révélations il a appelé des
journalistes qui enquêtaient sur ces
soupçons
edouard philippe a immédiatement
recadrer son ministre quand on est
ministre on ne peut plus réagir comme
quand on est un simple citoyen banon et
je comprends parfaitement que l'homme
françois verreault et était agacé
peut-être mais il en faut plus pour
faire taire françois bayrou qui ne cède
pas
edouard philippe dit il faut être
exemplaire je partage ce sentiment
j'ajoute et c'est aussi vrai que en
effet il faut de la liberté de parole
en tout cas pour moi je sais pas vivre
sans liberté de parole malaise au sommet
de l'état après un conseil des ministres
de 3h30
le porte-parole du gouvernement assure
que la situation est pacifiée y a pas de
tension particulière à l'heure qu'il est
il ya eu aucun échange particulier qui
pourrait faire état d'une tension est
donc je dois vous rassurer sur ce sujet
personne ne lâchait à commencer par le
garde des sceaux mais aussi les autres
personnalités qui sont au conseil des
ministres
même volonté d'apaisement ce matin chez
edouard philippe
il estime que les français ne veulent
pas de polémique et lui non plus mais
l'affront laissera des traces
d'autant que ce n'est pas la première
tension avec françois bayrou pendant
toute la campagne il a revendiqué son
indépendance et il s'était même empoigné
avec emmanuel macron sur la liste des
candidats aux législatives estimant que
le modem était lésée l'alliance avait
été sauvé après deux jours de tension
heureusement la raison l'a emporté je
pense que emmanuel macron a expliqué
certain nombre des cadres qui
l'entourent que ça n'était pas l'accord
que nous avions trouvé et je trouve ça
si nous y arrivons demain matin je pense
qu'on va y arriver je trouve ça positif
de son côté emmanuel macron reste
silencieux pas facile de se passer de
son garde des sceaux alors que celui ci
porte la loi de moralisation de la vie
publique
l'un des premiers grands chantiers du
quinquennat
françois bayrou est-il en position
confortable pour défendre ce grand
projet très symbolique qui est très
important de moralisation de la vie
n'est pas en position aussi confortable
qu'il aurait pu l'être à la à la fois
pour les raisons qu'on vient qu'on vient
de voir c'est à dire ddd des tensions
avec le premier ministre mais mais
surtout que ces tensions arrive sur un
sujet qui est précisément au coeur de
son texte au coeur du du message des
manuels macron qui est pratiqué la
politique différemment de manière à
redonner confiance aux français
la loi s'appelle heures une loi de
confiance il ya quelque chose de cocasse
quand même c'est l'antithèse donc
effectivement on a le sentiment images
et j'ai lu toute cette séquence en dix
ans font au fond c'est comme si on
envoyait sous nos yeux s'exprimer là la
différence de culture politique entre
plutôt une ancienne génération
c'est la vie politique c'est la volée
sur bayrou est un homme expérimenté il
une carrière politique d'une trentaine
d'années et puis cette nouvelle
génération une nouvelle façon d'incarner
la politique emmanuel macron edouard
philippe veulent un veut l'incarner si
ça peut vivre ensemble encore ça peut
vivre ensemble tant que certaines lignes
ne sont pas franchies j'imagine du côté
de du côté de françois bayrou parce que
françois bayrou qui était un allié
effectivement il a raison au moment où
françois bayrou retire sa candidature ou
ne présente pas sa candidature à la
primaire on voit bien que les intentions
de vote pour emmanuel macron remonte
tout de suite mais en même temps les
élections législatives montre que le la
république en marche n'a pas besoin
d'alliés donc il ya là quelque chose qui
est potentiellement on va dire un peu
délicat pour françois bayrou il va sans
aucun doute continuer d'exprimer sa
liberté de parole
il entend être françois bayrou tel qu'on
le connaît depuis longtemps mais je
pense quand même qu'il ne pourra pas
aller au delà de certaines limites fait
du feuilleton bien évidemment dans les
semaines à venir et on va suivre ça de
très près merci bruno cautrès et rendez
vous bien sûr dimanche pour suivre les
élections législatives pour vous faire
vivre ce second tour sur notre antenne
abouti de programmes cha cha
[Musique]